[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand j'ai rouvert les yeux tout était
sombre dans la chambre j'entendais
quelque part comme une sonnerie j'ai
voulu bouger a la douleur dans l'épaaule
droite tout à coup me coup pas le
souffle une peur affreuse m'envahit et
mon corps se couvrit de surur toute ma
mémoire me revint l la f les copains qui
se font descendre je suis blessé mes je
fond le FRC je glissa la main sous
l'oreiller la malette pleine de pill
était là bien sage de BRI e toute ça
pouvait aller mon esprit se mit à
cavaler sur était ma plan que j'ai suie
et bientôt à nous de la belle vie les
palaces le soleil la mer bleue toute la
vie toute la vie une radio s'est mise à
déverser un he de piano à tout cassé je
connaissais ce truc c'était le BL rondau
à la tou jouer comme un fou aussi vite
que moi mettant les bout s dans la
sonnerie du téléphone mon cœur fit un
bon je prie le récepteur alor c'est suci
ça fait deux fois que j'appelle
qu'est-ce qu'il y a y a un C de flic au
point de la route je restais sans vois
j'étais foutu il faut que tu files me
dit descend pas sauve toi par les toit B
Dieu bon Dieu bon Dieu bon Dieu encore
les frics vite le fric et puis
l'escalier de service 4 à 4 1 çaétait
ouvert sur les étoiles me Reva faisant
la mal parmi les antennes de télé ce
poignon je ne l'aurais pas volé 30 m
plus bas dans la rue du police cétait la
crue j'en veux plus j'en veux plus j'ai
couru comme dans ru long des
cheminées le temps la mala main je va
sur un toit un escalier
d'incendieenfon tout au fond
[Musique]
d'UE je
je
rue J
[Musique]
entr la boîte était pleine comme faisait
le
Bf
je broulais de fièvre je voyais les les
bouteilles qui
tourn par
[Musique]
jeourour clouant sur
place
Suzie n'en fais
pas je te
suis on y va le
soleil la mer
bleue toute la
vie toute la
[Musique]
vie
[Applaudissements]